entrepreneurs I like to be around so I
posted on Twitter not too long ago my
real interest lies in helping
entrepreneurs who want to make a
powerful difference in this world
and it got a response from wiki DZ who
wrote in to say how do you do that could
you elaborate on how you separate the
wheat from the chaff so this is a great
question and for me if I'm looking at
the people who I enjoy spending my time
with who I enjoy investing myself into
who I enjoy seeing their businesses
really take off and is worth my
continuous investment and dedication and
energy the two things that I look for
are one you have a passion for what
you're doing and two you're trying to
make a big impact in this world and I
have three types of entrepreneurs who
come to me okay the first they don't
have passion they don't want to make an
impact they just want to make a lot of
money and they recommend with things
like Evan you know what can I sell on
eBay that I can make 100 percent profit
margin on really quick you know they're
just trying to make a lot of money and I
don't relate to these people very well
because if you look at the most
successful entrepreneurs the ones who've
made the most money when they started it
wasn't about the money for them but you
never hear me talking about it being all
about the money when you focus on the
money doesn't come never your comments
at least you're gonna be on that that
wheel just running running running in
circles you have to do something more
important you have to do something that
you're passionate about that's how money
comes money comes when you follow your
passion and so I try to educate and sway
these kinds of entrepreneurs to do
something that they're more excited
about and that this concept of just
trying to make money isn't gonna work
for them because I I care about them
right you know that's why I make the
video responses if you're that person
who's trying to make money I care but I
want you to make money but the way to do
it isn't just to try to make money and
so some people will change there's some
people they'll listen to that and
they'll open up their minds at some
point they're realizing that hey you
know what this just chasing my money
thing it's not happening so you know
maybe ever knew what he was talking
about I'm gonna try something new maybe
to reach bottom until you figure that
out and others they don't and they may
watch my response they haven't that guy
doesn't know what he's talking about you
know these are entrepreneurs who I still
enjoy helping out but it's the hardest
for me to connect to because they don't
have the right mindset yet and maybe I
can coach and help them along the way
but they're coming with the wrong
mindset which is which is hard to change
the second group of entrepreneurs are
the people who who have a passion so you
know they're chasing a dream they know
they love what they do and they want to
keep doing it and and I love working
with these kinds of people because
because this is your dream right like
this is your baby now you have a reason
for doing something you're motivated by
something more than money and when you
help somebody accomplish their dream
that feels so good right you know the
feeling if you help somebody do
something that was important to them
then that makes you feel good and so I
like helping these entrepreneurs the
challenge for me is there's tons of
entrepreneurs who are wanting to follow
their passion and I have a limited
amount of time and you know picking the
right ones and I'm always feeling
stretched that I don't know who to help
and so a lot of the the support comes in
formats like this you know video formats
we might do a Google Plus hangout the
reason is it's still a one to one
relationship where my my end goal what
you know when I leave this earth I want
to have made a difference I want to have
felt like I left this planet better than
what I what it came to me as and that's
really gonna come by helping tons of
people in a really meaningful way and so
I get a lot of joy and pleasure and
happiness from helping people one on one
but it's not scalable and so it doesn't
achieve my bigger vision the third group
of people and these are the people who I
really enjoy working with the most and
spend the most amount of time with the
people who are following their passion
and who are trying to have a big impact
and what I see it as is entrepreneurs
who want to build a movement and have
created you know a page on my website it
talks about movement building and
coaching program and I have and some
people look at that page and they were
like what is this all about I don't
understand this I'm just trying to make
a lot of money right those people are
gonna self eliminate immediately other
people will look at that page and say
wow this is this is this is what I
needed this is really important you know
and you may not be able to afford it but
you have the right mindset you know like
those are the people who I want to help
the most because by helping them if
you're trying to build something
powerful you're trying to build a
powerful movement beyond just selling
whatever product or service and beyond
just following your passion you're
trying to have a big impact in the world
then by me helping you out I'm not only
helping you in a meaningful way but also
millions of other people that's my goal
right I want to be able to have a big
impact so I want to help other people
who want to have a big impact as well so
those are the three kinds of
entrepreneurs that I deal with and
there's a lot of the stage ones who just
trying to make money there's there's
quite a number of people who are
following or passion but don't have
necessarily bigger vision and want to
build a movement and then there's a few
people who are connect with who want to
build a movement who are trying to do
something really important way beyond
themselves have a meaningful impact in
the world and those are the people who I
get inspired by - right I love working
with them we're we're on the same
mindset and I know that by feeding
energy into them their movement will
take off and explode and help millions
of people and those are the projects
that I feel most fulfilled by and so
that's how I separate it hopefully that
answers your question
believe I would love to hear your
feedback let me know what you think
please leave a comment below you have a
question for me leave it below in the
comment section and you want to see more
videos like this click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon